I've been so lucky
to have my sister in beauty at the desk,
co-founder of Milk Makeup.
Boy, am I gonna miss her on Monday.
But don't worry, she'll be back because we're like this.
It's Zanna Roberts Rassi!
Yay! Best week ever.
Best week ever.
BWE!
Highlight of 2020.
Thank you for having me today.
Well, we've talked about doing this for a long time,
so I'm just so glad we're finally here.
All right, Zanna, kick us off!
Okay, so she's beautiful inside and out.
We're starting with the lovely Chrissy Teigen.
Byrdie reports that Chrissy shared
her latest skincare secret on Instagram.
If you haven't seen it you must watch.
It's Le Prunier Plum Oil.
She slathers it on and calls it "holy and amazing".
As soon as you watch this,
I literally on the internet trying to find it,
trying to buy it.
It's obviously all sold out,
but it's eight times the strength of argon oil
and leaves skin glowy and delicious
and it's antioxidant packed.
Drew, it's amazing.
Do you see my face right now?
She's calling the development people at Flower
saying "We need to get plum oil."
I did exactly the same at Milk.
Not only am I excited and want to try it,
but this is the power of an influencer, social media,
a woman we all love, know, and follow.
I love her because she just says it like it is
and I really appreciate her humor.
But this is the power of a platform.
And that's why brands want to work with people,
because this sold out.
She's so authentic with it as well.
So she's frank and real and fun.
I am, I really,
I just love her, I'm a really big fan.
She's so refreshing.
All right, I've got some news about "Animal Crossing",
a video game so widely popular even I've heard of it.
My girls play it,
I mean, it's an all ages party.
Nylon Magazine reports that the games latest update
finally allows players to giver their avatars
natural textured hair,
and it makes a big difference to players of color
who might want their mini me to have locs or an afro,
adorable hair puffs.
And earlier this year
"Animal Crossing" made all skin types feel welcome
by letting players customize their avatars
with vitiligo, acne, psoriasis, I mean--
Amazing.
Such a genius idea and it's about time
they reframed all these conversations
that are notoriously negative
to something positive and celebratory.
It's like our UPS store this week but,
I think that was one of my favorite stories
that we got to do,
was allowing people to be who they are,
celebrating and supporting that.
Yeah, and being able to identify,
even if it is a video game,
to find someone they can identify with.
And express yourself physically.
This is who I am.
Live you look.
Live your look.
Um, #NewMilkMakeup.
Motto, yes, I can see that in Sephora now!
Live your look.
All right, Zanna, hit us with one more trend.
This is Trending in Beauty Edition!
Okay.
All right, so for those who celebrate Christmas,
you can countdown the 24 days with a beauty advent calendar.
Have you seen,
okay, so there's mad hype around these and for good reason--
I mean, Lucy's even excited about that.
But it's not the chocolate one you're used to, Lucy.
This is full on products.
L'Occitane --, Lip Smackers, they all have mega.
I mean, everyday, your kids are gonna go nuts.
Lucy is extra excited about the advent calendar.
You know what, for people as well who want to,
for brands who want to send out -- sampling
now we're not shopping in store, this is a great way.
And also it's such an amazing gift for someone
'cause you get a new thing every single day.
So Zanna is in the Two Girl Club as am I.
Her daughters are Rumi and Juno
and mine are Olive and Frankie.
And both of us being moms who work in beauty,
I mean, my girls are going to freak out.
They are gonna go,
they will never do one day at a time,
it's gonna be taking the whole 24 and juts unpacking it.
Look, Lip Smacker is doing one too.
I know, listen I love advent calendars
and it's so Christmassy and beauty.
This is perfect.
This is a great,
thank you for bringing this to our attention.
I had not known about these.
Oh my gosh,
and they're taking off on social media as well.
So you can check them out
and really figure out which the best one for you is,
because all the influencers
are actually opening them on the calendar
so you're like "Oh."
Because opening is the big deal in social media.
Unboxing, you got to unbox it.
(upbeat music)